david do you think vaccination
phases are ethical once you get to
vaccinating
healthcare workers is it really ethical
to limit who can get the vaccine beyond
that
i mean listen this is basic utilitarian
utilitarianism it's triage you
try to reduce the amount of death and
people who get seriously ill from covid
if that's the goal if we all agree that
those statistically more likely to get
a cold flu-like
are in one group and those statistically
more likely to die from covid are in
another group
it's completely utilitarian to say they
get the vaccine first so you would start
with
the oldest folks and those with the most
serious medical conditions there's
nothing
particularly unique about that it's
simply utilitarianism now
where it can get tricky is the practice
of figuring out where some of these
lines are so
for example throughout the pandemic
grocery store workers have been
essential essential workers we've heard
the term
but they've not been prioritized
we know that so many um grocery store
workers have gotten sick with the virus
and we're saying they're essential but
they're not being prioritized
maybe it's being done incorrectly but
the idea of figuring out
at least when there's limited supply who
can get the vaccine
first is perfectly utilitarian now
you can look at other criteria you could
say well
we want this to be egalitarian and so
we're going to do it by
lottery as an example you could make the
case that
that's preferable in some way it's not
likely to reduce death
the studies that i've looked at do say
that starting with the oldest and the
sickest
uh is is the way to reduce that death
and in fact we're seeing it if you look
at the numbers now
cases have sort of plateaued they've
plateaued right around 50 000 a day
and hospitalizations keep declining
and deaths keep declining now the deaths
are on a delay from cases so we'll have
to continue to watch that but that makes
sense
because you you tend to have people
behave in a way that's reflective of the
risk they perceive
there are definitely younger people as
we now learn
about more and more older folks being
vaccinated there are more younger people
doing whatever the hell they want
spreading covet is leading to cases
but the deaths and hospitalizations are
going down
because the most vulnerable have already
been vaccinated so i i do believe that
as vaccine
supply increases the restrictions
probably become
i don't know if the word is less ethical
but less necessary
and certainly any thawed vaccine should
be used no matter what there are some
anecdotal stories and we've covered some
of them of people who have been
um penalized and in some cases i believe
even fired
for using open doses which would go bad
if you leave them overnight
on people who did not yet meet criteria
i i think that's terrible
and to the extent that it's happening
anecdotally it shouldn't it's very bad
people we should be using every single
dose a docent in a trash can
is never better no matter what than a
dose in someone's arm but yes from a
utilitarian standpoint and this is
a common way to analyze some of these
medical ethics issues
um there's nothing um unethical
about the vaccine triage and it does
appear as though it's being done
more or less in the right way but there
are arguments to be made about well
teachers maybe should have been earlier
if they're going to have to be in
schools with kids
um if grocery workers really are
essential we know
a lot of them are getting sick they
should be on
i think you can tweak with with some of
the specifics but there's nothing
unethical
in principle one of our sponsors is
privacy.com they're giving you five
dollars when you sign up for their
completely
free service at privacy.com
i've been using privacy for a little
over a year now you've heard me talk
about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you give each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air it'll
even autofill the card number with one
click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at
privacy.com slash pacman